a bag has more green balls than blue
balls and there is at least one blue
ball
let b represent the number of blue balls
and let g represent the number of green
balls
let's compare the expressions two b
and b plus g which statement is correct
so they make a bunch of comparisons
between two b and b plus g is it greater
than less than equal or is there not
enough information to tell and so like
always pause this video and see if you
can figure it out on your own before we
work through it together
all right let's work through it together
let's see what information they are
giving us
so this first sentence they say a bag
has more green balls than blue balls
so we can translate that in math
language as the number of green balls is
greater than the number of blue balls
it also says there is at least one blue
ball so just translating that
mathematically we know that b
is going to be greater than or equal to
1. there is at least one but maybe more
so b is greater than or equal to 1.
so now let's com let's see if we can
somehow manipulate these so we can get
to some reasonable
sense of how b plus g
compares to 2b
well there's a bunch of different ways
that you could approach it and you might
find a way to approach it that is
different than my way
but the one that jumps out at me is well
i know that g is greater than b
and if i add a b to both sides on the
left hand side i'm going to have a b
plus g and on the right hand side i'm
going to have a b plus b and this right
over here is 2b
so just like that i know i can keep the
inequality if i'm doing the same thing
to both sides if i'm adding or
subtracting the same thing to both sides
and so just from g is greater than b if
you add b to both sides of that we can
deduce that b plus g
is going to be greater than b plus b or
it's just going to be greater than 2b
and that's all we need to do and let's
see which of these choices match up to
that so let's see all these have 2b on
the left hand side so we could rewrite
this as 2b
is less than
b plus g
and that is
that choice right over there